[Music]
there's already been over two years
since game of thrones concluded with its
eighth season the series finale caused a
lot of debate among fans and critics
alike and some were not highly satisfied
still the producers want to make up for
it
the first spin-off series will finally
be released next year with house of the
dragon the targaryens golden age and
westeros will be highlighted
find out exactly when the series will
take place and what we can already
reveal about the plot in this video
but how did the prequel actually come
about
originally a completely different series
called blood moon was being planned the
pilot episode had already been shot and
the plot was promising it was supposed
to be about the age of heroes and the
first battle against the white walkers
it was the time when the great house of
the starks and lannisters were founded
and took place about 8 000 years before
the action of the main series however
the executives of hbo were far from
satisfied with the pilot according to
insider reports they were concerned that
the series might scare of long time fans
which is precisely the group they wanted
to win back after all thus the series
was officially cancelled and house of
the dragon was promptly introduced the
story about the dance of the dragons is
less enchanting and more about politics
and scheming just as in the first
successful seasons of game of thrones 10
episodes were directly confirmed without
seeing a pilot episode
now before we talk about the eagerly
anticipated plot we need to take a
closer look at the cast as it is through
them that we can deduce the events from
the centuries old story
as the reigning king and house of the
dragon paddy considine takes the role of
viserys
viserys targaryen the first of his name
was considered a kind and loving king
who was highly respected by the common
people
he was also the last rider of the dragon
valerian on whose back aegon the
conqueror took the seven kingdoms
viserys had seven descendants who will
also play a major role
counsel down is already well versed in
medieval intrigue having played banco in
the 2015 hollywood film macbeth
one of the main roles in the series will
be occupied by princess rhaenyra
targaryen
she was the first born of the king and
of pure valyrian blood she liked to
dress herself like the warrior queen
visenya targaryen the wife of aenon the
conqueror plus she was a dragon rider
herself specifically that of the
she-dragon cyrax
in the series rene is embodied by emma
darcy
up to now she has mostly played small
roles house of the dragon could thus be
her breakthrough in the world of acting
alison hightower the second wife of king
viserys also has an important role to
play she was the daughter of otto
hightower who was the hand of a total of
three rulers she grew up in the red keep
and was considered the most beautiful
woman in the seven kingdoms at the age
of 18 she married the king to whom she
gave four children
ellison is played by olivia cook she is
best known from the drama sound of metal
the blockbuster ready player 1 and the
series bates motel
prince daemon targaryen was the younger
brother of vasiris unlike his sibling he
was not known for his easygoing and
cheerful nature but more for his
swordsmanship
he was one of the greatest heroes of his
time and will of the long sword dark
sister which of course was made of
valerian steel after two marriages
without a son he finally entered into
marriage with his niece princess
rhaenyra
together they had two sons aegon iii and
vasiris ii
daemon is played by matt smith he's
surely known to many of us as doctor who
and of course prince philip in the
series the crown
otto hightower the hand of the king was
a loyal supporter of the kingdom
he served a total of three kings as hand
although two of them dismissed him as
the father of the listened hightower he
joined her in trying to assert his
grandson's claim to the throne which
eventually led to his deposition he saw
prince daemon targaryen as his greatest
rival as well as a threat to the kingdom
it was not only his wild warlike nature
that displeased the hand rumor has it
that he also deflowered his daughter
otto is played by rhys ivans who most of
you know as the father of lunar lovegood
from harry potter
carlos valerion also known as the sea
snake will feature in the series as well
house velaryon originated an ancient
valyria and settled in the seven
kingdoms as a feudal house of the
targaryens coles for his part went down
in the history of westeros as the most
famous navigator ever he's said to have
led his house to such wealth that they
possessed even more gold than the
lannisters moreover he's believed to
have been in command of the largest
fleet of all time he was the husband of
rennes targaryen who was known among the
common people as the queen who never was
corliss is played by steve tucson he's
known from the video game adaption
prince of persia the sans of time
reign is valerian the wife of corliss is
also likely to be seen often the queen
who never was was simply passed over by
the great council when it came to
choosing a successor to the iron throne
since the council did not want a woman
to be in charge of the seven kingdoms
she was the writer of the dragon males
and a feared warrior in the series she
is played by eve best the british
actress was last seen the netflix
production fade the wings saga what
would a game of thrones series be
without people from the free cities
pulling the strings behind the scenes in
house of the dragon that's missouria the
beautiful dancer from lisz was sold from
one slave trader to the next until she
finally ended up in a brothel in king's
landing it was there that damon
targaryen took notice of her and made
her his mistress
sonoyo mizuno will be playing the role
of missouria finally there's sir kristen
cole he was the simple son of the
steward of house dondarium he became
known for his sword skills rising to the
rank of lord commander of the kingsguard
fabian frankel who recently appeared in
the netflix production the serpent will
take on the role of coal
finally let's move on to the plot here
the new series has a decisive advantage
over its forerunner the story has
already been concluded needless to say
we won't reveal the entire story we will
only briefly cover it as we can tell
from the characters the series takes
place about 150 years prior to the
events of the original series this means
that the happening surrounding egg and
the conqueror will at most be shown in
flashbacks the story of the dance of the
dragons will be narrated this describes
the civil war between the two opposing
parties from the house of targaryen on
the one side is alison hightower who
wants to see her son aegon ii succeed to
the throne after viserys death on the
other side is rhaenyra targaryen the
first born child of the late king who
would be the heiress according to the
official succession
this gives rise to two parties which
call themselves the greens and the black
council this civil war will go down in
the history of westeros as one of the
bloodiest to which most dragons will
succumb
the first season will probably tell the
power political prehistory to the dance
of the dragons
for as you may have noticed an important
cast has not yet been announced that of
again the second also the show is not
supposed to be as brutal as the original
series
this is mainly due to the public
criticism of the downplayed sexual
violence against women in game of
thrones
whether the prequel will match the
quality of the old episodes remains to
be seen
after all the show took 8 seasons to
develop complex characters however the
creators have shown a season 8 that they
can also end the series in a flash
filming on house of the dragon has
meanwhile began at levinson studios in
london as opposed to northern ireland
and croatia as was the case with the
previous series
the plan is to finish post-production by
the end of the year of course george r.r
martin is again present as a consultant
however it is doubtful whether he will
be able to devote much time to the
project
after all he also wishes to finish the
story of his song of ice and fire in his
own words ryan condle who previously
worked on hercules and on rampage was
signed on as a showrunner he will be
assisted by battle of the bastards
director miguel sapochnick thus the two
will take over the duties of d.b wise
and david benioff who are the focus of
criticism after this season 8 fiasco
most importantly fans can look forward
to return of composer rameen jawadi who
famously composed the music for game of
thrones the first season will include 10
episodes although nothing is known about
the over length so far the budget has
also not been disclosed however one
episode of the last season costs an
average 15 million us dollars the series
will be released in 2022 but it is not
clear yet whether it will be on the
first or second half of the year
alright that's it for our preview of
house of the dragon what do you think
have you been able to get over the
frustration of season 8 and are you now
ready for new adventures from westeros
or are you still so fed up that you
won't even watch the new series we
believe that at least the story offers
great potential and could result in a
good show as long as the creators at hbo
have learned from past mistakes let us
know what you guys have to say in the
comments it is clear however that this
will not be the last series in the end
there will be a total of 6 series from
the game of thrones universe next
project is a series about the tales of
dunk and egg these are stories about the
lord commander of the kingsguard lord
duncan and egan targaryen v
we are excited
see you next time
you